I don't want to be the frozen rosin for
the stream but I'm gonna freeze until
someone challenges me hey it's a
challenge made in one it's hard to stay
still for so long I like to avoid
blinking really not easy chest with
Chris trying to sleep some people watch
my stream as like a sleep aid from what
I've personally YouTube comments I'll
try and not make any loud noises 50 bits
from
remedial sin thanks for the bits what do
I play insists let's play something new
I usually play d5 I think this game I'll
go for it's kind of a simple Kings
Indian h4 h4 is I mean it should just be
dubious I could just ignore it
let's just ignore it if h5 I can just
take I mean there's times when h4 is a
good move but there's also times where
it's incredibly premature and immature
c4 let's play c5 I want to treat this as
a Benoni
and I'm envisioning my bishop just
landing here because usually in Benoni
white sometimes likes to play h3
preventing Bishop g4 I was watching a
SAM Shanklin lecture for a st. Louis
chess club he gave two lectures on how
pawns can't move backwards they're
actually really good luxuries I think
I'll take here and then I'll actually go
for d5 and we won't really have a benoni
setup it'll be more like a iqp setup or
whatever this is
just continue developing probably d6 I
could consider d5 let's play d6 a handy
Andy it's been a while since I've seen
that name 200 bits is a sermon on I
would play a sermon if he wants to play
some rapid or even classical but he has
to challenge me
I don't like sending challenges I had a
bad experience yesterday I tried to
challenge chest Network and John worth
all of you and both of them were not
accepting challenges the rejection was
very painful
a3 I would like to complete development
this Bishop doesn't have a great place
to go yes I could play e5 maybe a castle
play a 6 trying to figure out what I
want to do with my life in this position
Bishop g7 maybe maybe I will play a six
a six is useful move because in cases
where I play e5 there's no annoying
Knight b5 to attack the pawn and in
other cases probably more long-term I
would consider breaking up the Queen
side did the best win of my life feel
better than the worst win or the worst
loss ever felt I think I've suppressed
the memory of my worst loss but now I'm
trying to remember my best win I hope I
didn't suppress that memory my best win
was probably like winning the national
k12 championships as an underdog
I just went upon Andy
I think I can and like in the final
round I beat the top seed with some like
weird opening okay so I'm up a pawn wait
I can't cows
yeah I'm up a pawn and Exchange and I
have the bishop pair so what to do
coin a five hangs a queen because Queens
move far distances Queen b6 maybe as a
move
creating a battery also maybe playing a
little bit of pressure on the Queen side
hey chest with Chris one a quad today
hard to win more than three games in a
quad tournament and your readings going
up solid 95 so ignoring f2 but attacking
Queen I don't know if I can take on f2
without facing danger 95 is actually a
good move
trying to calculates maybe Queen a5
first I should be very careful here
and queens also kind of tied down to c7
so I might just move back to d8 it looks
ugly but I don't see really what else to
do in these other lines like taking off
too I don't think works at all so that
was a mistake that Queen b6 looked good
at first maybe I should have taken the
Knights and then just Bishop e6 rook B
one's a good sign that means white it's
not going to destroy me right away now I
just want to just want to consolidate
develop I have no idea who this username
is dual stream with xx etc I'm not sure
what that's referring to I want to do
like more collaborations though with
like other streamers like matches or
hand and brain hopefully within a few
months can organize something so what to
do here this is raided and there's no
increment I have to move quicker maybe
I'll just take the Knights and Queen
takes though it's actually kind of
annoying
maybe this move okay try and stay
focused the benefit with rook c8 is that
there's no no more issues with my c7 so
like if before I think I can just move
my Queen start taking stuff
I can't really leave my queen on a five
because white is threatening to win the
Queen after getting out of check so this
looks kind of greedy but a pawn is upon
and maybe I can start or continue
invading yeah that's some attacking now
f2 you seize it okay let's just trade
we'll trade some more get into an
endgame up the exchange up now what two
pawns if I can count
another wait that's not a sub that's our
raid that's a gigantic raid GN been fine
gold uh hello to all the GM men Feingold
viewers all these roars and attacks I'm
in time trouble and I'm trying to not
lose focus and not flag there's so many
people The Last Samurai it's so easy to
get distracted but I can't lose rating
points to this guy I can't give him what
his username says let's make a pass pawn
maybe I shouldn't trade pawns I don't
want to trade pawns I want to promote
any pawns do I have okay first of all I
want to win secondly I would like to
make like six rooks in honor of Feingold
so let's win some pawns let's drop the
bishop win some more pawns
whoa okay I usually don't do this but in
odd oh it's although Queen I forgot it's
although Queen I was gonna make like
some bishops or some Knights just for
Ben okay maybe that was slightly rude
but that was also slightly close good
game made in one so for those just
joining I'm taking challenges if you
want to play me you have to challenge me
you can type an exclamation point
challenge in the chat and click the link
in the meantime I'll try and answer some
questions I'll be here for US
Championships yes I'll be in st. Louis
starting either in the 19th or the 20th
so I'll be there basically the whole
time I might be also moving to st. Louis
at some point in the near future so that
would be exciting
I'm gonna accept a random challenge and
we'll see if this is still working I was
doing this in one of the earlier streams
it's actually you can't see it but if I
move the window up now you see it you
can see my council my JavaScript council
some people use us to cheats
I use it to accept your hand challenges
math dot random this better work okay
basically what it does it searches
through the elements and clicks a random
one of these 999 look at that donation
number over zero donating nine dollars I
can't see the message I'll have to go
back and see what that message was wait
i'm playing john davis 59 is a surreal
john davis i think this is a real john
davis yeah cuz i played him the other
day
this is just a random challenge I'm
gonna play the [ __ ] you're countering
gambits this is like the only person or
one of only maybe two or one of a few
people that I have an emote for and also
the Last Samurai has an emote for so
people can use their john davis emotes
in the chat this is a rated game so
we're actually going into a lion which i
played at least a couple times in
yesterday's stream and I'm pretty sure
John Davis was watching this is still
all prep play this a couple games last
night I'm just hoping that he's not too
well prepared so I think objectively
it's dubious but if White doesn't know
the refutation it's difficult for whites
yeah Knight c3 is a good sign I believe
Knight c3 is just a mistake but it's the
most natural move which is why I like to
play this for black now I think there's
two moves for whites there's this and
there's this I think this is a main move
I have Queen Daisy for rook e8 95 it
gets messy because I'm not immediately
winning anything
it was also Knight g5 which I ran into a
couple times yesterday 95 novelty kind
of what is 95 95 it's a move Knights
defended I could win the pawn and then
why could maybe trade Queens okay let's
calculate Queen takes Queen c4 Bishop e6
I mean I like the position because I'll
be ahead in development I'm castled if
white doesn't trade Queens as king is
just stuck
anything else to consider here Queen h4
check g3 yeah let's do this
and now the at Bishop e6 okay so the
opening was like pretty weird but now
things are sort of simplifying the
positions still a little bit weird like
White has one piece developed very
strong post in the center but everything
else is on the back rank I have a couple
bishops hoping to do something like what
do I do with the bishops Bishop b4 check
maybe retreats always retreats right
there should be six the problem is c4 is
it's a little bit weakening to certain
squares because pawns can't move
backwards now on do I play knight c6
except some ugly pawn structure but I
get rid of the Knights I could play III
that might be that might be too much
III Bishop c3 like what is my pawn doing
there wait a minute III winds up on III
Bishop c3 rook takes f4 I like free
pawns III now before it doesn't work
let's do it okay I kind of forget all
about the chats
it's weird whenever I stream and I play
a game like the chat and the board
compete with one another to like grab my
attention they're like fangirls or
something anyway let's take the the pawn
cuz why not oh we had another sob
blooper thanks for subbing
and let me try and find that message
from the 999 guy I know if I can find it
donation donation I was in stream labs
so it doesn't show up on Twitch so
confusing I'm really liking this
position because I'm up upon I have good
development I have a safe King White has
a fork which I forgot about I forgot
Knights couldn't move backwards I could
take another free pawn though like why
not
it looks risky because my rook is like
in White's territory aligned with the
bishop but I don't know if I can punish
it
okay show me what you got
cuz he could take takes Bishop d4 maybe
win the pawn back and then I
counter-attack along the second another
sub zap eight seven seven thanks for
subbing for some reason my stream labs
like the thing has not updated oh wait
maybe it did oh so number over 0 the
donation message was fine gold rosin
bughouse stream I think that would be a
little too crazy
I haven't played buck house in a while
we cool to do like an over the board
block house stream but that could get
messy ok what to do I'm up two pawns
Bishop each use a good sign maybe white
wants a castle do I just develop let's
just develop it's like a totem pole on
the on the C file single file line so
white castles obeying opening principles
or middle game principles I could play
rook c8 just to complete to try and
complete the totem pole probably not a
great strategy white noise
zero zero zero zero gifting 20 subs I
did not hear any white noise until how
the subs were gifted thanks white noise
trying to distract me from this very
important game I'll triage I'll try to
read off the sub names after I make my
next move I kind of want to do this with
the threat of taking and then this with
check
that would be pretty sweet la roque t8
open file while so many names
can I read off all the names before John
makes his next move
let's try mascar in the robot doctor
kudex ax Pollock Wisco badger nulls
Zelda shadow try Orion that you know and
X cl4 W was at it
oh no there were more oh man I have to
scroll up further loco dolia mix Toya 2
2 1 be jealous Stirling Albury bad news
757 generic rhymes with Erik white male
is that me trace for two for two for two
I am a noob uh keyed T and I got loud
today
I think I read them all and he made
those next move just in time
sorry if I mispronounced any names it's
hard to read when so many words and
letters okay maybe I can move this up
okay let's focus I'm down on time but
I'm up in ponds and I'm up in subs 94
maybe yeah look at this whole cluster
pieces I feel like this is a type of
situation if you show to someone who's
like just learning the rules of chess
like they have no clue what's going on
here but to a high level player you kind
of get a sense of what's going on like I
just want to fork but white wants to do
stuff this is where arrows come into
play so many arrows so beautiful so I
could just take and trade everything we
trade on e 2 we trade on D 1 I have
Bishop g4 in the end what's good enough
anything else
important that this comes with check so
it's forcing there is rook t8 but
thanking f7 yeah all the new subs can
use your your John Davis emote but I
think we made like the or I made the
observation that John Davis is only a GM
on Twitch but he's not a GM on the chess
which is probably preferable a king f1
we can I mean I can play workout for and
that looks kind of fancy rook F for King
II one rookie two and going for the kill
I do have to manage my time there's no
increment hey it's a new name zoo blarf
first time on your stream only a
beginner in chess but I saw a couple
videos and loved them
well thank you always good to hear is
there anyone watching who doesn't know
how to play chess also so many more subs
20 more subs there's more names to read
but my time is running and he's not he's
controlling the promoting square do I
move the bishop
let's move the bishop and read off more
sub names I think I accidentally
defended against Bishop takes g7 and
ninety-six check Oh
let's move the booth he wants to play
kini to remove the bishop back if King
e2 I'll play Bishop b5
gee I'm John Davis and the chat saying I
don't know how to play chess
so John Davis could potentially stream
Stipe but I don't think doing a
much of a job of its least in this game
I'm gonna play g5 because why not attack
the Knights create more loot for the
king
Wow let's check again this is where
bishops are just so good when they come
in a pair because they just like they do
maximize a number of squares you control
I might even have some mating nets I'm
gonna play this h5 controlling g4 so I'm
controlling all these squares and the
idea is - I'm threatening like main in
two or three with Bishop d6 it's already
a mating that so he defends against a
mate he wants to win a pawn I could
attack the knight I really want to like
still orchestrate this mating idea but
how it should be 41 there should be 5
King f3 I could just like play a waiting
move being super greedy like holding on
to my pawn okay let's read off subs
um Jimmy button Zola Mickey v one brute
lock oh I have to move let's play let's
go control the center best way to
control the center is to put stuff in
the center running with the pawns toads
so Hanny's three four three four
Bizet nickim c5 looks nice attacking the
knight and then if ninety two its force
mates please play 92 you know you want
to block here the pawn I he didn't do it
oh he wants to win this pawn
I have to be careful cuz now the bishops
controlling e1 what do I do here e -
let's just win a - I guess and I'll have
the Queen side majority I don't think my
technique has been that great but my
fans have been great the sub count is
great what are these new names
Shaniqua magic cubed Zack rules B
squared a - Ally WWE buju napo - 1 7
nepal Miyaichi s Carvajal King Goldman I
have to move I could push let's push a
king Goldman 9 to 6 Montclair 300mg
weirdo and boy laws okay let's focus no
more looking at the chats I think I'll
play this to start restricting the night
another common endgame idea put your
Bishop 3 squares away from a knight so
the Knights restricted I now the night
can't really move back towards the
center if it does I take it and now I
want to promote the pawn I think I'll
start with this and then I think I want
to go for this and then this yeah John
is being sneaky
let's attack this not the most sneaky
move but sometimes you don't have to be
sneaky to win a game I just want to win
b2 and then I'll have a pass C pawn
these pawns are blocking it back their
own pieces did I play this and hope for
g5 is you're gonna play g5 and then just
get mated aah oh this is all so close to
mate let's play this to start g5 it's
still mates eetu i forgot about let's
play this wait am I just meeting next
move Bishop g6 is coming if g5 Bishop f3
I think he has to play Knight f4 and
then I just push stuff should be good
enough
hey it's meat I was closer than I wanted
it to be that was a nice finish to
bishops yeah these pawns they were
supposed to be a strong points but
really they just kind of strangled the
the White King a nice game much better
than game than yesterday
what was it yesterday or two days ago
the first game we played wasn't the most
impressive this was more of a fights
yeah I recorded some like video lesson
on this exact variation with f5 fifteen
hundred bits from immense Imani thanks
Amon Somani oh yeah it was two days ago
no mercy even for generous people I
think i-5 is um like the one of the
lesser common moves if we check the
opening database yeah its lesser common
but much higher scoring than another
moves
so if you're an e5 player and you want
to play this line as black this is one
of the lines to know and as far as I
know Knight c3 is a mistake I'm in some
money with a sub and there's more gifted
subs by white noise 20 more subs okay
let's try and be slightly instructive
and bits from jumping someone can't even
see that jumping chess horse
thanks jumping chess horse I'm not
playing blindfolded I say it was playing
blindfolded I mean I only play
blindfolded like when I close my eyes or
when I turn the blindfold settings on
but haven't done that in a while yeah so
if you're a Kings gambit player and you
run into this which probably won't
happen too often unless you play me
that's my was Bishop e3 I'm pretty sure
like this is the refutation at least
stockfish approves of this like already
like plus a decent number because Queen
takes d5 what happens
I take stakes and then Knight c3 and
then yeah there's pressure on this and
why castles Queen side quicker so it's
important to trade off the bishops first
the rest of the game
[Music]
yeah 95 was interesting if Queen takes
e4 I would have played a Bishop f5 our
Black has all the fun yeah I was about
to reject III until I find it 1 upon not
the easiest position for whites maybe GE
3 Bishop g2 is more solid at least but
yeah then things went a little bit
downhill and then even more downhill
when I'll tell for me ok I'll try and
read more subs I'm I mean every word
that I speak I lose a little bit of
energy but thankfully I'm drinking tea
but I'm drinking like sleepy time tea
which is probably not the best source of
energy oh I do have a blindfold command
but that was that was when I was doing
blindfold streams maybe I'll do another
blindfold stream at some point
Gotham chess in the chat what's left
Gotham chess watching the commentary a
lot today like I was gonna do commentary
myself but then I mean saw these
beautiful people like Robert Haas Anna
chess and then the other stream with
like Gotham chess alexandria bow tez
John Bartholomew made the guest
appearance
it was great to see can I read off sub
names let's try how long will it take me
to read off 20 subs hopefully within 20
seconds let's try some of these names
are difficult ynw a 1991 moon cool ooh
food for hacks we Jaeho eyes elfis
general Jar be jumping chess horse
camasta one two three a cab one-arm
command tags 24 macho 9j Chester 87 yo
numbers hot pockets bones sky newgen 1 2
3 norbert noodle hn 2 0 knox bones
terminal speed i think i read all of
them man whoa it's bits from john davis
it's 10,000 i
I have trouble counting zeroes because
my eyesight is bad that's 10,000 bits
saying things for the game well the
things for the bits thanks for providing
people with some lesson of what not to
do in the Kings gambit and that's why we
have a john davis emotes maybe we knew
that white noise emo to like all these
new subs I get more emote slots ok I've
dirty for pending challenges if this
were a week ago I would like struggle
with indecisiveness but thankfully
JavaScript exists so let's use some
JavaScript also thanks for the subs I
didn't mentioned adieus and Earthman 91
yeah this is like Oprah where everyone
instead of getting her car you
essentially are getting a sub javascript
i have to open the command council what
did I do
whoa it's ten thousand more bits from
john davis oh but that's I think that's
from earlier because the sub
notifications just stopped but thanks
again John Davis okay I'm opening the
council I'm doing math dot random and we
have the next victim immortal sky
sovereign a good luck but not too much
luck let's play e4 and let's play I'm
gonna try and play aggressively I'll try
and play gambit let's play the King's
gambit let's teach John Davis how to
play this opening effectively watch him
play like d5
and get into the same thing okay I'm
gonna play Bishop c4 I forgot what this
variation is called but it's fun it's
especially fun of thought plays Queen h4
because at first it looks fun for black
but it's all about having more fun than
the opponent an idea with this Queen h4
struggling with arrows Queen h4 King f1
then white just develops like really
quickly even though it loses casting
rights
d6 is a little bit passive just control
the center this is one of the reasons to
play King's gambit as a level level
probably below like 1600 a lot of
players will play in some style like
this where I can just get a
dream-come-true Center Bishop g4 let's
play nine of three like very natural
developing moves nicely in the chat or
it's nilesy miles he just arriving
always telling me to play the grab I'm
so thankful I didn't play the grab this
game d6 is a fischer refutation well
isn't there a chess base article that
the King's gambit is refuted and the
only way to draw is like Bishop e2 on
move three but then it was later
discovered the article was published on
April first but there are a lot of
people who believed it I'm almost out of
tea but thankfully I have like at least
two more cups of tea in this thing
but it is decaffeinated by the end of
the stream I'll probably be like 90% tea
but that'll be okay okay I have like I
mean this is what you teach beginners
just develop control the center castle
okay so d5 now there's a rule in chess
is that whenever the center opens up it
favors whoever is more developed I'm
pretty sure I'm more developed question
is how do I take advantage of the
situation and I should probably take
probably take Bishop b5 castling and use
the center files maybe throw in Queen e2
Queen e2 Bishop e7 I could take on b8
there's Bishop e5 check immediately
let's start with there should be five
see what he's up to
what are my favorite teas it depends on
the situation
towards the end of the day either sleep
eat iron or chamomile actually my
favorite tea which I don't have
currently I want to get more of it's
called Egyptian licorice you can only
get it I think on on Amazon or Whole
Foods which is basically the same thing
now but it's so good it's like spicy and
sweet like this position Queen e2 maybe
Bishop e7 I don't want to like provoke
lock to Castle let's castle first
I might first start with like rookie one
might consider like bringing the Queen
to g3
I want to unpin mikemaya my Knights so I
have 95 in the future because that could
be very nice best instructional tea
content I actually want to like become
more massive masterful in the realm of
tea because I feel like people are still
criticizing me that I don't make like
property with like loose-leaf I'm just
putting teabags in the hot water so once
I learned that like the mastery of tea
maybe I'll start a new new channel so
there should be a category on Twitch a
livestream drinking tea what do I do
here Queenie one castle in Queens
I mean ideally I would like to prevent
black from castling but I don't know if
it's possible there's h3 h3 [ __ ] of h5g
for Bishop g6 95 let's do that looks fun
I'll give black the choice what to do
with this Bishop I do have a new a new
te mode though it looks like this
there's something along those lines
oh there's a category called just
chatting which is basically every stream
right Wow my friend just sent me a
picture do i show the picture on stream
look at this picture it's so beautiful
like look at this just sharing the salad
it's like amazing salad okay so we're
gonna take on f3 now I have the bishop
here and it's actually just more
comfortable now that this Bishop is gone
my queen has access to g3 if it wants it
I'm expecting black to castle year and
when black castles in light is unpinned
and then it's attacking d4 so I'll
probably go for something like rock a d1
okay yeah simple move like there's this
thing in chess if you have a have the
worst placed piece that needs to be
improved just improve it
don't spend any time this is
multi-purpose
I think the eventual goal is to attack
on the Kings side a question is how I'll
be starting with Bishop g5 Bishop d6 it
had the right intentions but I think
it's just going to end in like some huge
disaster because now the not only is a
knight attacked three times it's only
defended twice but also the pawn is
attacked
so I think white might just be winning
material here milk plus T equals yuck
depends on the T if it's lemon tea I
agree but if it's black tea like English
breakfast don't people in England put
milk in their tea
I grew up putting milk and like English
breakfast tea wait I might have to take
back what I said about being 90% tea
because I have to be at least 50% Pad
Thai that percentages are confusing so I
will give credit to my opponent like
despite maybe not playing the most
impressive opening like he's holding on
like not a lost position by any means it
is difficult Bishop e7 was probably the
best move to break the pin now if I want
to win the pawn I could take I have six
and then take on d5 but then things got
a little bit messy some I dude with
moral support and bits thanks so my dude
how long am i planning to stream for
till I run out of tea or until I got
tired let's play Bishop wait Bishop d3 9
takes d4 Bishop takes h7 it's also kind
of a mess
I don't want to do something here I'm
not sure what I'm tempted to just play
like King h1 this is like tennis where
you like the ball comes to you and
instead of like smashing it or doing
some crazy shot you just kind of lob it
back and see what your opponent does
hope your opponent just whips the ball
or shanks the ball like Shanklin and
just for signs and $20 from both man I
didn't see the message always late with
these notifications both man said or is
it off man 91 this for your YouTube
lessons big fan from KSA what's KSA
Kazakhstan South Africa I actually don't
know the first places that came to mind
Oh Kingdom of Saudi Arabia I should have
known that I guess the K threw me off
because usually I just would refer to it
as Saudi Arabia that's cool what time is
it in Saudi Arabia has to be like and
it's kata you just usually switch the
a.m. to p.m. like afternoon night before
when is night before attacking the spawn
I could retreat the bishop I think I'll
play rook F to being very patient
defending maybe preparing the triple up
have a gun on the that file
the lights kind of not doing nothing but
my bishop is also doing nothing anytime
I could play a three but anytime but I
can play a six time is running low hmm
8:50 a.m. oh so only eight hours I had
not too bad
okay I'm gonna move the bishop back this
way and I do have a plan of improving my
pieces and the plan was to play 92 c3
and Bishop c2 and then just start kind
of just migrating things to the Kings
side ideally I would like to have some
eventual attack with every single piece
except my king
I did have Bishop f1 if if Ben was still
here I don't know if n is still here
maybe I would play Bishop f1 but I like
Bishop a4
okay let's triple up not sure if I have
a threat it just looks nice maybe it's
some time I'll play Bishop b3 like this
is a I'll lonely pawn b5 okay
that's okay to be induced into playing a
good move
there's also ideas of 91 to e3 to f5
which looks actually really nice this
also looks nice trapping the knight
Creek c6 was probably one of the only
ways to get the knight trapped I have
been to Boston I forget when though I
was there for chess it's been a while
oh it's pronounced Boston Boston yeah I
thought it was pronounced Boston like
boss I was watching this video the other
day like breaking down what is it the
New York accent or the Brooklyn accent
where they pronounced Oz as Oz it's
actually like kind of nice to to listen
to there's not too many grandmasters who
have that accent John fedora wits
Lenderman Gotham czesc and awesome chess
can do a large variety of accents I have
to step up my impression game so I like
impersonate these interestingly speaking
players okay let's take the Knights so
I'm finally out material and still up on
time I'm realizing 94 is a move 94 five
actually went back some material they
can dig with check don't play 94 okay
good take it
let's move back with the bishop I'm
gonna preserve my bishop maybe put it
here yeah I only caught the end of the
second PCL coverage was Gotham chest
doing impressions
Rizzoli's doing something entertaining
okay
threatening to take and then win more
material ready to play this in this whoa
what does this move I take the knight
and take the Queen let's trade in 93
yeah I watched almost all of Robert and
Anna's commentary they're very
impressive because usually after like
one or two hours I just got so tired
they were going for several several
hours let's play this I'm dreaming of
Knight f5 g6 and Knight h6 meet that's
not gonna happen anymore let's do this
trade some more
and now black has this double pawns I'm
tempted to play rook h6 just to induce
more double pawns but that would be that
would be too much
there is a game in the PCL today where
black had triple pawns on the H file
which I've never seen before it only
lasted for a few moves but it was so
unusual okay let's just keep taking
pawns and now I'm gonna go up the board
nilesy asking do I need an opening for
the next game yeah if people want to
suggest openings let me know in the chat
well it's a rucksack okay
have to mate in the quickest way
possible well he left the game I think
all the rage quits or maybe ass losing
connection because now it shows he's
back well good game yeah that was some
nice opening have to play King's gambit
more often I just say often and my
opponent lasted like it was it was a
better position I don't know if I
completely optimized my advantage like
around here and maybe d5 was just a good
move stockfish how do I play chess takes
takes I think these are positions where
sometimes stockfish will find like
amazing moves but maybe nothing too
amazing
ok h3 yeah I just had to allow clock to
castle and me slightly better well oh we
have a large collection of openings here
what do we have to grab obviously well a
few people asking about the grab what's
the boat has gambit if you're gonna
suggest an opening that I probably
haven't heard of before you have to
explain what it is also the Jerome
gambit I have no idea what that is or
the reverse Mexican defense no idea
Alekhine I know what that is I know what
Halloween gambit is Evans gambit
Icelandic
move 21 why didn't you just take with
night b5 this guy knows how to suggest
move numbers it's good question actually
if I take on b5 I don't know if I even
consider this but the night kind of got
stuck good run into this and then maybe
there's Bishop a4 I just had a very
clear plan of like getting my knight to
the promised land where I would then
become a knife also these are double
pawns I'm not too concerned about
winning another pawn when I'm already up
a piece but maybe I could have
considered it another sob beak doc for
six months requesting things for all the
chests how about Kings gambit accepted
well that would require me to either
play it wait the scheme was a Kings
gambit accepted your wish was fulfilled
after you uh or before you asked for it
but if I'm locking in and I get myself
into a Kings gambit maybe all I'll
accept it okay oh I'm in Simoni once a
London okay so let's accept another
challenge do the JavaScript thing math
dot random new game I'm playing chess
two three four so I need black openings
Black Lion I'd forget exactly what that
is time on a Sicilian Dutch it's hard to
play the Dutch easy for Carol come let's
play CARICOM
[Music]
he's playing quickly I feel like he's
kind of knows what he's doing
I have three is actually a very trendy
move these days I'm scared because I
don't know any theory here but I should
just develop normally probably let's
play g6 like a g6 just feeling cadeau
castle get the King safe making sure I'm
not getting needed I'm playing this
because if I ever play c4 I would be
comfortable I'm not going to resign yet
that's Castle c3 so this is I think a
common idea I think I'll start with
knight c6 just complete development do
you like my fianchetto as a poker
commentator now I'm gonna play Bishop a5
and even though I don't usually play
caro-kann almost ever this is one idea I
know from the caro-kann where blackouts
this nice kind of solid structure and
then goes for King h8 rook g8 94 has
some attack so b3 white wants to play c4
interesting let's start with King h8
I could be kind of tricky and play Queen
d6 he'll play Queen d6 preventing 95 as
well when Queen d6 was tricky because
now I think I'm winning a piece just
have to make sure that this just wins a
piece my opponent wants to take back
do I give him the take back I want to be
the one to make that decision what do
you think chats until I give my opponent
a take back or do I decline it and make
him suffer the consequences
nah no yes no no mercy not allow no only
once give him a kick back nay no yes
take back once no no no ha ha
no take back well if I just spend the
rest of the stream reading every single
comment in the chat
nenene
ok take back declines send him your Pay
Pal info first that's a good strategy
maybe make a start of business doing
that ok
so White's trying to well first tried to
take the move back now trying to get
some compensation the Queen is very safe
safe and sound on b8
oh good I mean I could take the bishop
or I could just leave it suffering for
the next few moves what to do maybe this
move like night this is interesting
Knight g4 hey it's ginger 64 with our
aid thanks ginger 64 a long time no see
I think also streaming on me chess it's
the second rather the stream I don't get
raids too often always nice to see I
think I'm gonna play Knight g4 wait
Knight g4 Knight g5 looks kind of weird
that's okay though I think there's a way
to like disable take-backs all right
like the even the ability to accept
take-backs maybe it would be worth doing
trying to imagine a situation where I
would give a take back maybe if it was
like an obvious mouse slip atomic
shoelace with a sub two months thanks
atomic shoelace I take this I mean I can
still take it don't really want to take
it how long can I play the game and
leave the bishop just attacked by the
pond because the goal actually the goal
is very simple to play Knight f5 and win
this guy okay now the bishop wants to
retreat so now it's time to capture once
the trade of knights okay can trade
nights now Knight f5 hitting the rook
pressuring the pawn very soon I probably
want to play Queen f4 looks nice
now I have three attackers on the pond
still at some point I haven't had the
time to do it yet but I still not go for
this eventually and not get some other
needed but if I can get a truck to g8
it's just so much easier to attack I
can't even like kick away the Queen
because I would take the night-time time
control for challenge anything 10
minutes or below would be preferable but
that's I guess this is the one problem
with the JavaScript command is I can't
really or I don't know how to filter it
based on time control but yeah do
something reasonable if it's
unreasonable I probably just abort it or
I let the chat decide how to handle it I
said some other made and I'm I'm having
like a night I was about to say dreaming
of this scenario but I was having
nightmares of scenarios where I put this
here in here and then the night comes to
f7 and that would be bad is this a free
pawn looks like a free pawn because OD
pawn is pinned now the C files opening
you can pick casual or rated I don't
really have a preference I don't really
care too much about my online ratings I
sometimes go through phases where like
I'm above 2400 now so I carry slightly
more but I'm still going to take every
game slightly seriously
have to maintain my my pride and glory I
have a Rick post and I have four
attackers on the pawn which is still
pinned to the Queen I don't know how
that's relevant though we can Queen
trade I guess and then I'll win another
pawn and then we'll trade some more and
we'll trade even more so lack is up a
bishop I'm only up one pawn
I guess cuz he won my pawn when I won
the piece I could win another pawn here
here take stakes yeah let's play this
first because this pawn wants to just
start running and this Bishop wants to
start eating let's push up on push
another pawn maybe I'll make a pawn
chain push another pawn is he gonna take
the poison and get pinned it's happening
I might torture the rook for one okay he
just resigns tough game yeah unfortunate
blunder but that was fun playing like
Heroku I played this really one of the
only in caro-kann ideas I know at least
after the opening because you don't see
this idea too often where like you get
your you trade off bishops and this is
actually a good transformation of your
black I think one of the reasons why
white blunder it is like usually this
Bishop is safe but not when there's a
pawn enough for so I'm happy and queen
d6 worked out okay
can you post your J s commands yeah if
you want the actual code for it I'll
just copy and paste it in the chat or I
can copy and paste it in my discord and
then people have to go to this court to
find it's no copy and paste in the chat
um hopefully it doesn't ban me for
sharing code there you go
so people can use this I think it works
in any browser we just opened the
council I guess you need multiple
pending challenges for it to actually
function the way you would want it to
London with Knight c3 so the job pavel
london maybe do that oh I was also
wondering may I pose this as a question
for the developers who are watching but
it would be nice to have a I don't know
JavaScript command or extension where I
can accept random challenges just from
twitch subscribers I think that would be
a little more difficult you have to like
use a twitch API is and a chess API is
but maybe it's possible Angela the
London someone asking what does this do
I'm gonna show you in slow motion you're
ready for it can you enter your code in
slow motion
wait okay so here's how it works I open
up the council I'm on a Mac so it's
option command I and this thing pops up
and because I've already entered the
command before I just press up arrow not
people can't see there it is I could
maybe explain what this is doing it's a
little bit cut off essentially here here
we have the code so man it's been so
long since I've like actually studied
code let me try and explain what this is
doing and this might be inaccurate but
essentially it starts by looking for
what you call this the challenge class
because every element on a website it
will usually have like a class name and
then it picks a random number of all the
challenges of however many challenges
there are that's challenge dot length
currently I have 33 pending challenges
and then it finds the accept thing which
is here and then it clicks and then the
game starts so it's really just magic
let's click and it starts the game and
now I'm playing Brandi Oh 11:37 now I
think there's some element within the
like random algorithm or it does take a
look at like how much you donate and
he's you donate more then it's more
likely you get accepted at least that's
what happened with John Davis oh I'm
playing okay I'm gonna play a javo
London I usually play normal London he's
playing f5 I can't resist I'm playing
the London or know that what is this the
grab against the Dutch there should be a
name for this oh it's console it's not
counsel yeah I think that makes sense or
how would you say it if you're from
Boston console no I can't do
impersonations or accents all right I'm
gonna I don't what I'm gonna do here
probably see for soon let's try and open
the position as much as possible
oh console console I think d5 was
actually like the best move
after g4 oh it's canceled
doesn't sound right
console all right let's put the bishop
on that for so these are like the two
defining moves of Java London usually
the pawn maintains itself but too late
let's play Queen b3 attacking the bishop
supporting the Knights
maybe I'll go for Roxy one soon because
the C file will open someday also the G
file is already open let's play Knight
f3 defending the pawn getting ready to
play rook g1 my king just might stay in
the center
not a bad square play rock G one this is
the first blitz game in a while feels
nice playing blitz very fresh play III
solid move defending things getting
ready to develop the last minor piece
[Music]
let's take it so now the bishops
attacked the bishop moves back
what to do I want to attack maybe Bishop
h6 is interesting
hitting G to work out seven Knight g5
rookie 7 c5 let's do it
ooh I think there's a good move here for
black maybe it's not too devastating
there is this move but then I think I
have this should be okay
Karpov gambit says Carlsen wins most of
his games by doing nothing hmm probably
have to disagree with that he does do
something but his moves are so deep that
they seem like nothing but they're
actually a lot of something so I'm gonna
go forward with this variation this was
my initial calculation if they're
working moves here I trap the bishop
with c5 and if he ever takes us Bishop I
unleash the rook the second game in a
row I'm trapping the opponent's Bishop
with the same kind of mouse coordinates
the same area of my computer earlier is
f4 and I was black this time at c5 and
I'm white wait a minute it's not trapped
h2s hanging but then Ritchie - and then
it's trapped okay but he might win this
bishop so we might be trading I don't
know okay good thing I ever g2 still
waiting for this move pawn takes h6 I
would have Knight takes c6 winning the
Queen
whoa should have been listening to the
stream actually I don't encourage people
to listen too closely when they're
playing me if they want to that's okay
but if they won't if they don't want to
that's even better
okay I'm winning the Queen and then
maybe later the bishop or the pawn I
could take the pawn to then Bishop let's
take the pawn this is a quadruple fork
I'm attacking this and this and this and
this and most importantly this and this
everything's attacked some things are
defended but some things aren't offended
what are the odds of black defends
against maiden one also what are the
odds that block just flags in this
position okay well black flag resign or
get mated three possibilities or will I
lose somehow hopefully that doesn't
happen resign mated mated fried lose
neither oh he defended me let's develop
a bishop I'm not taking anything even
though both bishops are hanging mm-hmm
wanted to play Queen g8 but now both
works are defending let's take a bishop
still threatening mate in one
not seeing mates let's move this way
resigns I don't think too many people
said resigns Atomics truly said resigns
few other people did too okay
36 pending challenges who's challenging
me maybe I could like play someone
manually I'm so spoiled now I don't even
have to even look at the list some
interesting names here lot of people
challenging me to like 10 minutes some
blitz games no bullet games alright one
more okay playing header 2011 that was
like eight years ago
oh I'm white I'm what opening do I play
last game I mean people wanted me to
play Joe pave London but it didn't quite
work cuz the guy played the Dutch so
let's try and play Joe valve of London
and I know some ideas I don't know this
as well as like normal London play
blindfolded I'll try and play
blindfolded for one move okay so my
mouse is on e one this is what hoodies
are for see if I can make a legal move
but you have to tell me when it says
move or I'll just guess or I'll pre move
let's pre move
so my mouth should still be over the
king which means let's move the pawn or
the Knights move the pawn to e3 so let's
move up a little bit and then I want to
move here to that work hey it works
III I played on one move mine folded
let's play another move line folded wait
but I have to wait until no I don't wait
until he makes a move I'll just wait a
few seconds but what's my next move
don't want to move the pawn again
probably the bishop so move the bishop
from f1 or the Knights did that work
maybe I'll try it again
did that work I'll try again I'll try
again until something works
oh I'm just highlighting it's too
difficult well let's play Knight f3 that
didn't work at all what if I would have
yeah that would have been bad if I click
the resign button if I click the resign
button there's it gives me like a
confirmation right I don't even know her
test hits let's play Bishop e2 a hapa
shove g4 would have been dirty by black
in this position cuz I wear the plate
III blindfolded that would have been so
bad alright let's play 95 this is one of
the main ideas so like go for a 5 really
quickly trade off bishops
could do a challenge where I pre move
every move I could be difficult though
some moves would not be people and some
captures would be hard to predict
click resign once I don't want to though
it is casual do I do it what does the
chat think if the chat wants me she
won't do it of course everyone's gonna
say do it once ah ok that was nice I
think there's a setting where you can
like turn that off so it doesn't ask you
if you want to confirm I feel like that
was very dangerous it's like Russian
Roulette or something ok let's play g4
g4 or queen maybe i queenside castle no
let's play g4 let's see what black is up
to interesting game dogs I think we got
the best of all the worlds like I did it
but the games not ending everyone should
be happy let's take the pong or the
bishop with the pawn
I kind of forgot about this this is a
slight problem because now this pawn is
hard to defend actually I've taken miss
Bishop I think with Bishop I of f4 the
good news is it's only a pawn maybe
there's some way to get compensation
queenside castling takes takes takes e4
yeah let's do it
maybe e4 sooner if you don't like ads
you should subscribe and then you get no
ads wait he is a subscriber huh Oh ads
referring to adrenaline is that what ad
stands for okay take sticks and then e
for this was my original thought I think
it's actually effective because I attack
this guy three times and if black
defends I take and unleash the Queen now
there is D for D for the pawn is pinned
maybe d4 f4 that's still interesting
- in the chat I was up so late last
night I was about to sleep but then
Manos kept bugging me for a game so we
play the game that was an interesting
game it was kind of equal then I kind of
had some advantage by losing another pot
I always play King b1 and then think I
don't know if I'm losing another pawn it
takes g4 I'll win d5 I takes takes takes
oh but if I take t5 I got fort this
could be bad the good news is that with
every pawn I lose I gain an open file
which could actually be useful so if
Queen digs g4 I probably avoid the Queen
trade I play like Queen III that way I'm
threatening rook g1 do this quickly
if flack over queenside castles is these
ideas if lock castles this way there's
these ideas if black leaves the king in
the center there's these ideas so even
though I'm down to pawns
I have ideas did anyone watch not gonna
slaughter Hansen last night
you can't spell slaughter without
laughter I watched some of it but that
was just getting repetitive like knock I
just kept winning it was like watching a
badly produced TV show where it's so
predictable like some people were having
fun though I only started streaming a
year ago I won't know if my chess
playing has increased or decreased it's
probably increased online but decreased
offline can i play queen a7 looks fun
pretty sure my opponent miss SATs
maybe allow that I don't know now if
takes on that it's mason fine so
blockhouse who keeps the D file closed
this might be a move but then I check IP
eight and then takes this is looking
very fun I'm still yet to win a single
pawn but it's okay network TV the only
network I'm familiar with these days is
chest network who was streaming
yesterday I think are the day before
technically he started streaming before
it was a cool thing to do such a hipster
let's play Queen eight if King here I
win the pawn black would then win an
open file Knight b8 holding onto the
pawn but maybe losing this pawn my
Queens kind of stuck a little bit
uncomfortable
well I'm winning upon back this is a
very strange position but I'm up on time
there's no increment so time is kind of
important I'm dreaming of takes takes
and then meeting on e7 in this case I'm
just winning the rook I have a feeling
black is imagining the sign where he
gets to work my rooks but then I very
easily defend with like either rook to
d1 so this is looking very good I'm up
to exchange now for a pawn the main goal
is to knock it back ring mated I've
actually never played have I played
doctor drunken Steen I don't think I've
ever played doctor drunken Steen I've
played doctor night der Steen twice once
was a chess960 game and I've played man
with a van once but they're all the same
person rights they're just different
mental states of the same person I guess
one of them is a car state okay so I
have a D file complete control where's
my mating idea I'd have to bring a pawn
into the action I wanted to play Queen
a7 but the Queen now controls a7 so
let's play a for creating loosed for the
king
making the German viewer is excited that
I said looped probably what I'll do is
maybe someday double up somehow or maybe
even like go back and attack the b7 pawn
okay so Bach has a very clear plan to
make another lady I need a clear plan
let's play start with this or this or
this you'll start with this I like the
kind of being on b3 because it couldn't
help shelter the king you have to be a
sub to use emotes I guess that's true
there was an attempt use the Fabiano
emotes
I need a Magnus emotes i don't think i
have a mag Massimo's maybe once Magnus
can get a plus score against me then
I'll make a magnet emotes okay let's
play let's play rook b3 hitting the pawn
threatening mate in one block has some
idea of mating me but it would be a
tempo too late
this could get very messy little I get
flack play as b6 what do I do because
then there's a monster threats
I be six maybe a five queenie one okay
still threatening mates
time is running low also now the group
can't come to you one so be six so I
want to calculate here here takes takes
King g7 maybe just rooks III or even
rook c5 could be very very fancy rook c5
takes takes here here Keeney seven takes
it should be good enough I think
I'm utilizing pins like both pawns are
kind of pinned and then the knight is
also pinned so I'm threatening this if I
get rook takes me six I'm just winning
Queen e6 pinning back that's annoying
maybe C for breaking the pin but then he
can take and then run
hmm yeah let's move this way I think the
plan now is to just bring my queen to a
more useful square like get out of the
corner and into the center is inviting
Queen eight again let's start with a
five whoa there's a little bit
unexpected
okay so takes takes couple checks couple
more checks can maybe take here takes
takes check and then meets yeah looks
good enough
[Music]
okay if you have King da left queen AIDS
GG yeah interesting kind of weird
situation there I think my opponent was
better when he started winning pawns and
then yeah things got very weird but this
position that I would think stockfish
would know what to do it's got to be at
least minus one D for D for kind of
keeping the center somewhat closed and
taking on g4 make some sense okay I'm
kind of tired what breed of dog
it's a west highland terrier small and
white like a pawn any other questions
has Eric ever defeated someone in the
top twenty in chess world rating in
normal games not online like normal game
over in war game like in a tournament
the highest ranked player I've defeated
was Ivana Savage
who at the time I think was like top
hundred maybe he was like around 100 in
the world one of the top players from
Serbia I think I was like 2,300 fidei
about this was back in 20
like in college jet could have been like
2012 he was like 26 50 feet eh I beat
him cuz it was like drawn and he just
completely over pushed that he over
pushed offer me to draw whenever a GM
offers you a draw it's usually a bad
sign for them though I wanted like two
more moves
I have to find that game it was not
Sarek Ivana Savage who maybe used to be
the top player in Serbia maybe's Sarich
has passed and when's my next over the
board tournaments
maybe something in st. Louis like st.
Louis runs EES like rapid quads or the
Saturday tournaments for like one
evening so probably nothing big I might
play a tournament in Montreal actually
though if there's anyone from Canada
watching it's probably late in Canada
but I might be coming to Canada only
time I've been in Canada I was in the
Toronto Airport which I don't think
really counts my score against Caruana
we've only played online I remember
playing him once on ICC got a long time
ago not sure if the game will still be
saved and we played a bunch of games on
me chess we actually played on me chests
like right before I started streaming
and he was playing on someone else's
accounts I only had found out afterwards
that I was playing him he beat me like
90% of the games but I did give a
lecture on like one of the games I beat
him in the London yeah if you came late
you're just in time for the conclusion
of the stream I'm just trying to answer
questions you're just watching my
youtube video attacking a passive
opening yeah I try and like label my
videos with something intriguing but not
necessarily like to click baby or if it
is clickbait it will like live up to the
expectations do I have a day job I have
a mix of jobs but I don't have like a
the normal 9 to 5 I did an internship
once I was like a 9 to 5 awesome
office job for two months and it was a
good experience but made me realize that
I don't know if I want to commit like
the traditional lifestyle hey it's
another sub child Traeger a lot of new
subs the stream again thank you to white
noise I think we may have broken 700 if
I'm not mistaken but yeah my jobs
include I guess nowadays chest streamer
youtuber private chess instructor I'm a
coach for like a couple high school
teams photographer web designer what
else done commentary I check Jam tea in
the chat what's up patching JMT is doing
math earlier and by math I mean like
math dot random making big bucks from
streaming yes um someone donated $20
white noise donated so many suggs yeah
but I'm gonna have to take off like
right now I'm so tired all the mods all
the mods are here someone should start a
stream so I can read them
we also streaming Manas you should start
a like instructive stream okay oh yeah
also yeah big bucks for were made the
other day john davis who've i played
twice now giving so many bits and so
many ponds
okay always a sermon streaming let's
raid that sermon so I realize other day
is that when I raid someone and I click
read it doesn't transfer or it doesn't
end the stream right away so I think the
other day I rated and then like there
was a minute where I thought the stream
is over
I was just liking a sermons chat okay so
mark a sermon I never know his twitch
username because there's so many what
look at that like how many Y's there are
one okay I'm not going to count I pasted
it maybe pace and now I can copy it and
paste you got your first chest book
congratulations now you have to read it